In some of my recent writings,
I've argued that,
you know,
global trade does seem to be driving
down wages for unskilled or semiskilled
workers and countries like the United
States in western Europe.
And I think this is an important
political issue.
You know,
there's no question that inequality has
risen in the United States.
Um,
wages,
you know,
for ordinary workers have been fairly
stagnant or have only risen a small
amount,
you know,
while incomes at the high end of the
salary scale have gone up a lot,
and at the very top of the income
distribution,
you know,
incomes have gone up spectacularly.
So I do think that's a very important
issue.
I would argue that trying to address
that by restricting trade is not likely
to succeed.
You know,
it makes the whole country poor.
Uh,
it's a bad way to treat the developing
world.
The developing world is benefiting a lot
from this regime,
you know,
so if you look at the whole look around
at the whole world,
you know,
do you want to try to pursue a solution
in the United States that's going to
make the poor countries poor?
Uh,
that doesn't appeal to me.
I don't accept,
uh,
the notion that restricting trade can be
any part of a progressive agenda.
I like to think of myself as a
pragmatic,
progressive.
So I think when you worry about wages
for ordinary workers in the u s which I
do worry about,
I think you have to look at the tax
system in the United States.
I think you have to look at public
expenditure on education and key
services that actually reach ordinary
people.
So I think what Larry Summers is arguing
is that there are a fiscal measures and
policy measures you could take that
would really make life better for the
working class.
I don't think Larry Summers is arguing
against the free trade regime,
but I think he's smart enough to realize
that if you don't do something for
ordinary workers in the United States,
you may lose the political support for
free trade.
And that really is an important engine
of the whole global growth.